et fabrice di vizio à koper
fabrice qui est dehors en pleine rue une
heure fabrice di vizio qui n'a pas donc
pas de pas salutaire
mon fabrice mon ami celui qui est
vraiment devenu je le dis un ami fabrice
di vizio d'un garçon qui a des
convictions qui est un garçon qui va au
bout de ses idées et ils avaient dit
qu'ils n'auraient pas de passes
sanitaires
et bien fabrice il va au bout des choses
donc il m'a dit
[Musique]
[Rires]
fabrice dire est venu bonsoir déjà
fabrice pensons à
[Musique]
tabriz oui fabrice on dit tous ici et
c'est vrai que on s'est appelé en début
d'après-midi au lion à sept pétales
musique
on s'est appelé en début d'après-midi et
donc tu ne peux pas accéder au plateau
ouais je peux pas accéder au plateau en
effet puisque j'ai pas de passe a dit
hergé refuse pas vaccinés et j'ai refusé
catégoriquement de me soumettre un test
complètement débile qui sert absolument
à rien et qui vise juste à me
contraindre à faire quelque chose que je
ne veux pas faire si cette mesure avec
l'utilité servait réellement à protéger
les autres et que réellement nous étions
dans un souci de protection je leur ai
évidemment fait mais comme c'est pas ce
but est que ces call clairement assumé
qu'on cherche à me faire faire quelque
chose que je peux faire je suis pas ce
genre de mec moi c'est pas genre de mec
donc d'ailleurs il fait ça casse qui dit
mon mec à moi ça n'est pas fabriqué
vidéo
fabrice donc est ce qu'on peut mettre un
sou pour monter un petit peu le micro de
fabrice s'il vous plaît c'est rien c'est
une petite tranchée comme une tranche de
pain mais il faut la monter fabrice
aujourd'hui donc tu ne veux pas te faire
tester même donc tu ne viendra pas sur
le plateau tant que bas qu'en mon nom je
viendrai pas sur le plateau donc
effectivement il y aura un pass annie
terre parce que concrètement dans votre
plateau il ya des gens qui sont
vaccinées des gens qui ne sont pas
vaccinés j'ai tout à l'heure notamment
vous aurez laurent alexandre mais
laurent alexandre il est vacciné mais
est ce que vous pouvez me garantir que
s'il vient au plateau laurent alexandre
ne contaminera pas pourquoi moi je doit
garantir leur ans alexandre que je ne le
contaminerait pas et lui tu ne vas pas
me garantir qu'il ne contaminera pas si
laurent alexandre se soumet un test moi
je viens moi je les plains pas de
privilèges c'est eux qui avec l'inde
après village c'est les personnes
vaccinées qui aujourd'hui vous réclame
un privilège c'est tout le monde fait le
test même les pannes et bien sûr que tu
veux bien mais bien sûr absolument
d'accord mais j'ai aucun problème mois
de discrimination 1 c'est pas nous
alors d'accord et fabrice des vidéos
tient autour de la table sur ce qui ne
va pas on va pas faire le débat vendait
ce que tu as l'air bien entendu on fera
un débat sur êtes vous pour ou contre le
pass and it et on est obligé de le faire
aujourd'hui surtout avec le professeur
house qui sera avec nous est ce que vous
comprenez fabrice di vizio est ce que
vous dites c'est un nul hubert lui et on
comprend pas ce qu'il dit eux comme ça
on peut très bien ne pas avoir les
données scientifiques et les
connaissances scientifiques m'apprend
peut avoir les données logiques et là ce
qu'ils disent c'est complètement logique
et c'est quelque chose que tout le monde
peut comprendre donc à partir du moment
où il n'y a pas d'égalité entre les
personnes vaccinées non vaccinés je
trouve que c'est normal de le dire haut
et fort comme il le fait et bravo à lui
valérie b non mais c'est pas du tout
annuler un hurluberlu en revanche il ya
un pacte citoyen qui est qu'on essaie de
se protéger au maximum les uns les
autres moi par exemple mais je pense que
on met en me vaccine ans par deux fois
j'essaye de protéger au maximum ceux qui
m'entourent et moi même et je pense que
ceux qui n'ont pas envie de se faire
vacciner libre à eux mais leur paquetage
eux c'est d'aller faire un test pcr
c'est tout ce que maintenant on a une
semaine pour essayer au maine visite
pour protéger les uns les autres fusées
moi non mais vous considérez donc en
étant vaccinez vous vous protégez alors
je vais vous dire quelque chose ça vient
de madame sermine fakih qui est en fait
en l'occurrence effectivement la
responsable suisse du contrôle la fin du
centre de la santé les personnes
vaccinées sont aussi contagieuse quoi
celles qui n'ont pas reçu une injection
contre cowitz et virginie masserey qui
le dit la direction de la section des
maladies infectieuses et virgin et kenza
alors donc c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
ce que vous appelez le pacte citoyen
magie vous dire ce que c'est que le
pacte citoyen c'est accepter que vous me
conta minier c'est ça votre vision du
pacte citoyen est ce que vous acceptez
cette information que moi j'ai je ne
suis pas scientifique mais je ne suis
pas médecin local de presse j'écoute
j'écoute simplement ce qu'on me dit dans
la presse lui et on me dit dans la
presse les journalistes les
scientifiques ont été
les les publications scientifiques
disent que si je suis doublement
vacciner j'ai douze jeux contamine 12
fois moins au tour alors ça sert à dire
comme un fou attendent un truc c'est moi
si radicalement fait parce que ça c'est
ce qu'a dit le président de la
république lorsqu'il a instauré le passé
a dit terre de manière honteuse et moi
je vais quand même effectivement vous
dire quelque chose avec un moule lire
quelque chose encore le vous savez ce
qui se passe en israël vous avez vu que
ça flambe en israël est bien écouter ce
que dit le premier ministre israélien
devant la knesset qui est donc le
parlement israélien 1 sa date quand même
de pas très longtemps un point très
important que les gens doivent
comprendre et je pense que la plupart
des gens n'ont pas conscience et que la
population la plus vulnérable en ce
moment de manière paradoxale et celle
qui a reçu les deux doses du vaccin mais
pas la troisième pourquoi et bien parce
que se promène en ayant l'impression
qu'ils sont protégés par ce qu'ils
auront un ou deux doses ils ne
comprennent pas que la deuxième dose
s'est estompée contre le delta ils
doivent se faire vacciner rapidement que
la troisième dose de vaccin il y a
beaucoup de personnes jeunes vaccinés
qui sont gravement malades et
hospitalisés et j'ajoute un point vous
avez vu que le passage du ter ce que
vous appelez le pacte citoyen et bien
bientôt madame vous aurez droit à une
troisième dose et c'est à ce moment là
aujourd'hui vous n'êtes absolument pas
protégés et que le gouvernement
israélien vient de dire que le pass
annie terre ce sera à la condition
d'avoir les trois doses alors je vais
vous dire la vérité la vérité aller
simple elle est très simple il faut pas
parler de publications scientifiques
soyons logiques de minutes il ya une
volonté de discriminer il ya une volonté
de mettre à l'écart il ya une volonté
effectivement ni plus ni moins de forcer
les gens à faire ce qu'ils veulent pas
faire pour des raisons politico
financières ça c'est que ça concerne
mais moi en tout cas ce qui est certain
mais moi ce qui est certain vous pouvez
vous moquez tout ce que vous voulez mais
la différence entre chacun d'entre vous
et moi c'est que moi j'assume et
j'assume jusqu'au bout pas pour moi pas
pour moi mais venez en manif venez aux
manifs venez donc aux manifs voir ces
gens qui souffraient vous pouvez vous
moquer de la souffrance des gens tant
que vous voulez mais n'empêche
qu'effectivement venez omani voir la
souffrance des gens venaient voir ces
gens qui ont des gamins de 12 ans qu'on
force à se faire vacciner venez voir les
parents divorcés qui lisent a battu veut
pas effectivement payé l'impôt tu veux
encore notre soumettre la pension
alimentaire pas de problème je faire
vacciner le gamin venez voir combien ça
a déchiré la société ce patch qui ne
sert à rien qui est une passoire
sanitaires vous allez faire comment sur
le plan politique vous êtes bien entre
vous sur les plateaux mais quand demain
viendra aussi bien des apolitiques oh
non moi je suis bien mieux ici n'est pas
de comprendre quoi vous allez faire des
débats politiques des gens qu'un florian
philippot qui refuse effectivement le
passé a dit ah vous n'allez pas les
invités mais mais mais il était sur un
plateau à florent filippi et bien sûr
hélas on passe à nîmes et non il n'a pas
son passé dit heures à la salle demandé
à la non à banon moi j'étais chez jean
marc morandini on m'a jamais demandé
nous passe a dit m c'est la première
fois qu'on me demande c'est la première
fois sur cette émission on n'a pas fait
tout court c'est obligé depuis
aujourd'hui alors
c'est très fort ce qui fait fabrice
vieux c'est un acte de résistance ils
refusent d'obéir à l'absurdité que
représente ce chez nous parce qu'un
public assez pour ça chez jean marié
minssieux ya pas de l'ipc il a droit oui
voilà et moi j'ai eu le caviste était
donc j'ai eu un passe-temps n'y paraît
de fait pendant six mois mais sinon
j'aurais été avec lui dans la rue et
c'est très fort ce qu'il fait c'est une
image très forte en fait notre succès ni
maquillage très certainement
coupable ou je vous sens énervé la
kangoo dit fabrice dehors on m'a fait
très mal pour moi chaque hameau de ce
monsieur david sûr et comme un
équivalent d'un coup de poignard dans le
coeur pur bonheur ouais ça nous avait
droit monsieur vous avez droit
d'argumenter plus tôt peut-être dans le
pathos et c'est entre 10 et moi
attendent excusez moi un pour ma fille
non parce que je suis dehors
effectivement que lors du débat vous
voyez bien souhaiterait pourtant à
l'extérieur et participer à la vie
sociale imposera que c'est pas très bon
en extérieur rien mais donc la vraie
question que je me pose effectivement
moi monsieur ses caisses que dans ce que
j'ai dit est faux dit aux
téléspectateurs aujourd'hui qu'ils
gardent que vous n'êtes pas si vous êtes
vacciné que vous n'êtes pas contagieux
donc moi que si je vous approche
monsieur je ne risque pas de me faire
contaminer par vous dites le moi alors
paulo déjà on a quand on est vaccinés
c'est prouvé clair et net qu'on a deux
fois monsieur ces dingos monsieur c'est
ma peau mais je viens de dire que ses
petites fesses alors s il faut enfin que
j'ai aussi donné les saouler mais si on
part sur des postulats qui t'était par
son faux un tailleur ou à l'extérieur je
continue à dire la dernière chose vous
apporte quoi pas [ __ ] au balo alors que
ça se peut pas ça m'a ça pour quoi
pourquoi la saa sa main mais société
monsieur ne dit rien monsieur et dans le
mépris mais monsieur effectivement n'est
pas capable d'aligner un seul argument
monsieur vous me dites que ces douze
fois avez vous la moindre sujet avec
vous dès maintenant mais je suis
parfaitement quelle voiture et poser les
bases pour se plaindre ah oui j'ai pas
envie d'avoir julien combes et sur le
dos
borloo
est ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
l'ancien ont tiré sur la croix rouge je
ne sais pas une idée je voulais bréhat
l'arrivée d'une année qui s son dealer
parce que non on est complètement sol là
ça fait deux ans vous ai juste corson
vous êtes orson nous montrer je sache et
deux ans presque 18 mois qu'on est en
train de combattre tous dessus sans mais
pas répondu à ma question est ce que si
je m'approche de vous vous pouvez
considérer que vous ne me contaminerait
pas non mais par contre il de montréjeau
monsieur c'est une question extrêmement
importante est ce qu'aujourd'hui les
données que je viens de vous affirmer et
le parlement la knesset le premier
ministre israélien qui vient de déclarer
devant la knesset que les personnes
doublement vaccinés sont les plus
vulnérables car elles doivent à partir
de 12 ans aujourd'hui recevoir une
troisième dose est ce que vous vous
considérer aujourd'hui comme et protéger
d'une part et surtout est-ce que vous
vous considérez comme ne me convainc cij
avant le débat parce qu'on leur a le
débat tout à l'heure je connais dans la
la question c'est est ce que vous
comprenez fabrice di vizio ou pas on
rentre pas dans l'histoire de sanitaires
ou
citer un chiffre ça c'est vraiment on
l'a vu tout ce je vous cite le cas
italien la campagne de vaccination a
commencé cet hiver 10 ans elle a
commencé à entrer un régime au mois de
mars un mois après un mois et demi après
les comptes le taux de contamination
s'était écroulé de 80 pour ses enfants
si vous voulez en ituri frpi et de tout
le monde mais le sua est ce que vous
voulez moi je pense que vous vous avez
une grosse responsabilité aujourd'hui
monsieur l'espace de marley non non
c'est un trottoir si vous êtes en train
de vous adresser à des millions de
français il faut céder sa division
des salaires mais il vit pas bien tu
peux pas faire ailleurs tout monture
guillot ans quand je vois fabrice di
vizio je ne sais qu'ils sont d'accord
avec division mais quand j'entends ce qu
est la plus qu'ils sont pas d'accord
avec lui donc on a déjà paulo en plus on
va faire le débat tout à l'heure donc
c'est vrai que ça va faire deux fois
je suis sans joie le geste très fort de
fabrice di vizio je me pose une question
qu'est ce que va faire que va faire le
gouvernement des gens qui refusent de le
passer à lithaire et de serre vacciner
ce qui va les laisser dehors pour la vie
on sait qu'il ya des gens qui ne peuvent
plus travailler aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
ne peuvent plus rentrer dans des
établissements comme c'est le cas là
qu'est ce qu'on va faire de ces gens-là
s'avère qu'il est moindre et sa vie à ne
plus traverser votre enfance c'est quoi
votre réponse la réponse est simple si
je suis en train de créer une société
parallèle à ressort à la fin de semaine
une plateforme du type beurre ou un truc
du genre appelez ça comme vous voulez
qui va mettre en branle à silver qui va
mettre en relation que blabla carves une
participation collaboratif qui va mettre
en relation des gens qui choisissent de
vivre et bien précisément à la marge ça
existe déjà aux états unis encore je
vous avez des gens qui vivent à la marge
est bien plus qu on veut créer une
société parallèle créons une société
parallèle mais moi pour ma part
j'accepterai toutes les contraintes pour
répondre ollo j'accepterai toutes les
contraintes tout je suis premier à avoir
mis des masques en intérieur parce que
paolo dis ça mais pendant que le point
donc alors que le masque était
obligatoire vous ne l'avez dit vous
n'avez jamais mis pendant le confinement
vous vous êtes présenté en plateau est
aujourd'hui tout à coup voilà qu
effectivement vous vous présentez comme
les vertueux de l'histoire c'est trop
facile messieurs dames c'est trop facile
cette mesure n'a rien de salutaire tant
que les mesures étaient sanitaire je me
suis plié volontiers et j'ai été le
premier à le faire aurélie ces mesures
sont politiques et je refuse de me
soumettre fabrice est bien de voir
absolument alors parfaitement bien
dehors qu'en mars comporte on va voir ce
qu'en pensent les téléspecteurs gare
d'aywaille alors comprenez boufarik view
oui à 60,3 % et non
27 oui j'en parle pas on parle tant que
pasteur on comprend est ce que vous
comprenez que fabrice vidéo refuse de
rentrer dans la guerre 60 % de gens de
téléspectateurs qui nous suivent qui
sont d'accord avec vous fabrice